also meine these ist raus aus den
schulden rein in die handlungsfähigkeit
schuldenbremse 2023 wieder einhalten
wenn wir das letzten drei jahre angucken
dann haben wir eine sehr exzessive
schulden politik
in deutschland gesehen
teilweise bedingt durch die pandemie
situation alles richtig die frage aber
auch da muss man natürlich sagen sie
sind die mittel immer richtig ausgegeben
wurden aber wenn wir ehrlich sind haben
wir auch die ganzen letzten zehn jahre
die gute einnahmeentwicklung
situation des staates die ersparen ja
auch schon angesprochen hat nicht
genutzt und das land zukunftsfähig zu
machen sondern das geld wurde verpasst
die einnahmen und wir müssen wieder dazu
zurückkommen dauerhaft solide finanzen
zu haben wir bekämpfen mit der
einhaltung der schuldenbremse
die inflation weil wir den staat als
nachfrager ein stück weit zurücknehmen
schuldenbremsen einhalten solide
haushalte sind auch eine frage von
generationengerechtigkeit
und von handlungsfähigkeit insgesamt wir
müssen in diesem haushalt für das jahr
2023 das ist ja mittlerweile öffentlich
25 milliarden euro mehr für zinsen
ausgeben als im letzten jahr 25
milliarden euro mehr das sind fast das
doppelte des haushalts für das familie
und jugend ministerium also mit dem geld
hätte man sehr viel anderes machen
können als zinsen zu bezahlen und wir
müssen glaube ich grundsätzlich dazu
kommen das ist auch eine aufgabe für die
ampel hat ersparen sicherlich recht wenn
die ampel daten der anderen stelle auch
in der öffentlichkeit kritisiert hat wir
müssen wir dazu kommen dass
es zu guter politik nicht dazu gehört
immer nur mehr geld auszugeben sondern
am ende des tages muss man die
handlungsfähigkeit des staates stärken
das geht mit ganz ganz vielen maßnahmen
die auch kein geld kostet zum beispiel
handel stimulieren wir werden zeta
ratifizieren das hat die große koalition
letzten jahren nicht geschafft es lag in
ihrem koalitionspartner wir werden jetzt
die lng terminals für flüssiggas
beschleunigt bauen können es gibt einen
kabinettsbeschluss dass wir mit dieser
form von infrastruktur bau
beschleunigung auch andere
infrastrukturmaßnahmen beschleunigen
denn das kostet alles kein geld und wenn
wir dahin kommen und nicht fokussieren
wer als erstes am meisten geld ausgibt
dann wird das land
bekanntes tv-format die ich auch solche
sachen schon mal aufgedeckt haben dass
ein betrieb brücken gebaut werden die
nicht wohin führen und die leute diese
halt so erst durchbringen kreis nicht
die müssen halt auch mal das zur
verantwortung gezogen werden auch wenn
es mit ihrem persönlichen einkommen ist
weil das geht nicht wir müssen wirklich
aufhören die steuergelder zu
verschwenden weil das ist auch so dinge
die uns halt dann sauer machen eine ganz
schwierige frage an politiker ist ja
immer die frage wo soll denn gespart
werden ja werden sie mich etwas
schmallippig also wenn man eine schulden
wenn man einen solchen bränden einheit
aber nicht wir sind immer mehr marken
stehen ja gerade mehrfach festgestellt
da sind wir abgewählt worden
ja aber dafür keine mehrheit mehr
gekriegt nein die frage ist ja richtig
nicht zurück oder sie wollen
also die frage lautet wo soll gespart
werden denn ganz ohne sprachen wird die
einhaltung der schuldenbremse nicht
funktionieren wenn wir corona die
bundeswehr und was sonst noch so alles
an deck das sind ja die zinsen haben sie
genannt das ist das laufen
ausgabenposten auf jede menge und wenn
man da die schulden machen will dann
muss man eben irgendwo sparen und nach
meiner lebenserfahrung ist das
doch immer ein ziemliches tabuthema
gewesen für regierende weil man sich
natürlich unbeliebt macht wenn man
irgendwo was kürzt da gehört natürlich
schneit dazu irgendwo was zu streichen
ja ich verstehe dass großes verständnis
dafür wenn sie da keine antwort parat
haben aber ich frage mich wie das dann
mit der schuldenbremse funktionieren
solle ohne irgendwo zu sparen müssen sie
erst mal ehrlich machen sozusagen die
hälfte des bundesetats geht mittlerweile
für soziales
darauf würden soziale
transfers investiert das ist rente dass
gesundheit
maßgeblich und natürlich müssen wir wenn
wir den haushalt konsolidieren wollen an
diese punkte ran das passiert momentan
im jahr 2023 relativ einfach weil viele
der korona maßnahmen auslaufen
zurückgenommen werden nicht weiter
verlängert werden aber natürlich muss
ihre nachfolger muss er lauterbach in
der gesetzlichen krankenversicherung
etwas tun darüber reden war ja in der
tat auch jetzt
die beiträge sollen erhöht werden aber
mit ja auch ein system der gkv als über
40 prozent so ja nein ich eben der gkv
müssen halt vom gesundheitsminister auch
entsprechende vorschläge vorgelegt
werden wie wir nicht die lücke waren ja
14,8 milliarden glaube ich die
lauterbach aufgerufen hat davon werden
zwei milliarden euro mit einem zuschuss
aus dem staatshaushalt belegt der rest
muss anderswo her kommen das heißt also
wir müssen am ende des tages sehr sehr
kleinen teile kann das wird im jahr 2023
noch nicht so schwer werden aber im jahr
20 24 20 25 wenn es auch um die
priorisierung der vorhaben der ampel
geht dann werden wir im verteidigungs-
diskussionen kommen sicherlich auch in
der öffentlichkeit da wird uns in der
öffentlichkeit auch in der residenz zu
ersparen also wenn sie jetzt die
entscheidungsgewalt hätten wollte ich
glaube wir sollten damit anfangen dass
sie im stellen körper sparen das fangen
wir jetzt auch an gerade 7000 neue
stellen geben ja weniger neue stellen
geschaffen als die große christus- und
im moment also sparen
das was wir am anfang was jede
bundesregierung am anfang macht ist ein
stück weit eine priorisierung zu setzen
dass es vollkommen legitim das ist in
dem fall auch einiges anstellen die zum
beispiel in der finanzverwaltung nicht
mehr gekommen sind wie hat ist ein ganz
anderes thema aber was wir mit diesem
haushalt 20 23 anfangen ist dass wir in
den ställen körper dass der
bundesrepublik eingehen wollen dürfen
wir werden eine pauschale
stellenkürzung von 15 prozent ansetzen
das sind 3000 stellen das wäre mir erst
mal durchhalten die müssen dann die
einzelnen häuser so umsetzen und das
wollen wir in den nächsten jahren
fortsetzen und so können wir durch jeden
einzelnen etat durchgehen und können
sagen das ist das stichwort
wirkungsorientierte haushaltspolitik
auch dafür haben wir jetzt zwei stellen
zunächst erstmal geschafft und dem
finanzministerium dass wir uns angucken
dass wir uns angucken was wir mit
einzelnen haushaltstiteln eigentliche
wirkung nicht bewirken und wenn die
evolution dazu führt dass das geld nicht
sinnvoll ausgegeben wird dann wird man
darüber diskutieren müssen dass man
diese projekte diese maßnahmen
entsprechend streich wir haben im
bildungsministerium haben wir sehr sehr
viele umschichtungen gemacht um die
bafög-reform also mehr geld für
studierende mehr geld auch im bereich
der forschungslandschaft das haben wir
aus dem etat 41 lernen jeden ein spar
ich mir ja wünschen ja was meistens kurz
sein berlin senders gegangen war wohl
dabei ja darf ich mit der mauer so in
einem guten jahr nochmal hier sitzen und
wir gucken mal will dass jedes land
aussagen ja
nächstes jahr mit erspart und herr meier
wieder hier